hey guys Mary here letting you know that
Telltale's Game of Thrones episodic
series is getting a second season CEO
Kevin Bruner confirmed the news is part
of a Hollywood Reporter interview
published today the confirmation comes
just days after the game's sixth and
final episode in the original season the
ice dragon which was released November
17 I'm pleased to officially confirm
that there will be a second season of
Telltale's Game of Thrones series and
that is already in development
continuing the story for a second season
was always the plan Brunner explained he
didn't divulge too much about what's
going to happen but offered a brief
tease the questions left on the table at
the conclusion of season 1 like who
survived and who didn't as well as other
choices you made play a huge role in the
second season things rarely go well in
the Game of Thrones universe and there's
always a price to be paid for playing
indeed the Foresters did have a very
rough time in season 1 but there's a
larger story to be played out the first
season of Telltale's Game of Thrones
series let players control five
different characters to see how the
story unfolds from multiple perspectives
Brunner said that you can expect the
second season to follow the same formula
but he wouldn't say if the number of
playable characters would expand or
shrink episodes in the first season of
Telltale's Game of Thrones series were
released for console PC and Mobile
presumably the same will be true for the
second round for more info on the first
season check out GameSpot reviews
you